Now I'll turn that into a question for you. How
should the scheduler choose the next thread to run on
the CPU? I'm going to give you four different choices. The
first is, first come first served. That is if I
have a bunch of threads, the scheduler says, well, which
was the earliest one that was ready to run on
the processor? That's going to be the one that I'm going to
schedule. That is first come first served. The second possibility is,
it's going to assign static priority to all the threads
so it's going to pick the threads that have the
highest static priority to run on the processor. The
third possibility is that the priority is not static, but
it is dynamic or in other words it changes
over time. And so what the scheduler is going to
do is pick the one that has the highest
dynamic priority. And the fourth choice is, its going to pick
a thread whose memory contents are likely to be in the cache of
the CPU. So these are the four choices, and I want you think about
it and come up with some thoughts as to what might be the
right thing that the scheduler might do, in picking the next processor to run.